Kylie Jenner is just like us she loves
post mates the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star is the latest celeb to
be featured in post mates spotlight
series the reciept where the company
broke down her orders over the last year
get this in the last 365 days Kylie has
placed 186 post Nate's orders 186 people
that's a post Nate's order every 1.96
days I did the math you're welcome the
grand total of Kylie's orders over a
whopping ten thousand dollars according
to the report Kylie's most expensive
order consisted of Don Julio 1942
tequila her smallest order a bottle of
smart water and a single carrot yep one
single lonely carrot the receipt also
revealed that the 21 year olds favorite
time to order is around breakfast time
at 10:00 a.m. but that is not all we
learned from the report during a photo
shoot in June Kylie placed five separate
post mates orders starting at 10:00 a.m.
with an order of one cream cheese bagel
four hours later she ordered a six-pack
of macaroon ice cream sandwiches four
minutes later she requested penne
Bolognese that was followed two minutes
later with an order of taquitos Mexican
rice enchiladas and a tostada salad then
four minutes later Kylie placed an order
for a truffle burger is anyone else like
super hungry all of a sudden I'm
starving
anyhoo Kylie isn't just throwing down
cash for food and drink delivery she
also had three cozy blankets delivered
to her hey why not
it's cold in here I'm gonna do it -
excuse me just for like one second one
cozy red blanket comin right up
Kylie's daughter stormy Webster turns
one on February first and according to
the receipt one week before baby
Stormies birth Kiley ordered Oreo
McFlurry z-- 10-piece chicken nuggets
and french fries
sounds like a pregnancy craving to me
and a sores recently told DT that the
reality star could be experiencing those
again sooner rather than later
apparently she and her boo rapper Travis
Scott are already talking about having
more kids quote Kylie and Travis are
going to wait until he's finished with
his Astroworld tour before trying for
another baby they want to have another
child soon so it's close an age to
stormy but they do not want to do this
while he's busy on the road the source
added quote Kylie's created a really
beautiful life for herself she has a
successful business that's close to home
she really loves what she does and also
loves that she can still be so hands-on
with stormy she really has everything
she's ever dreamed of and feels so
blessed hashtag blessed for real in July
2018 Kylie appeared on the cover of
Forbes magazine and the publication
estimated her net worth to be around 900
million dollars due to her wildly
successful Kylie cosmetics beauty line
so the ten thousand dollars she dropped
on post mates is less than one percent
of her total net worth Wow anyway that
number puts Kylie on track to become
America's youngest billionaire and her
famous fan tells et they couldn't be
prouder of her success it's not like
that was handed to her she figured that
all out I mean we all have she made her
own money for over a decade she put it
in the Bay she saved every nickel and
then when she decided she really you
know decided on what she wanted to do
she spent her money on a venture that
could have gone south or north and it
did really well